aujourd'hui on va se parler de mon
incroyable ipad à 2159 l'euro alors on
pourrait dire à 2159 euros est ce encore
un ipad mais à 2159 euros et bien l'ipad
n'est plus un ipad l'ipad est un
ordinateur est une bête de puissance et
un produit qui est complètement
exceptionnelle alors je vais tout vous
montrer jeu le tout vous expliquer au
début je me suis dit ah juste d'avoir
son mari pas de crocs et je vais faire
une vidéo où je vais montrer ce qu'on
peut faire parler des usages accueil pas
trop montrer ce que j'en fais moi tous
les jours et puis illustrer tout ça
alors ça ça arrivera mais dans un second
temps parce que sa taille pas de pros
quand il a été présenté
quand j'ai vu tout ce qu'on pouvait
faire avec et bien je me suis dit il
faut quand même venir expliquer ce
qu'est cette machine parce que je peux
dire quel nom d' ipad que d' ipad c'est
pas vrai parce qu'on parle quand même
d'une machine très particulière on parle
ici d'une machine qui se révolutionner
s'il ya une année où il faut venir
changer son ipad propre ou s'il ya une
année où il faut aller sur un ipad pro
et bien c'est cette année c'est en 2021
parce qu'en 2021 l'ipad pro est bien
plus qu'un ipad pro
[Musique]
pour tout savoir sur les pas de pros et
toutes les actus texte invite à venir
vous abonner comme ça vous saurez tout
et vous serez les premiers informés sur
les nouveautés tech
c'est très facile pour vous abonner très
simple petit bouton rouge ici vous
cliquez dessus vous actionnez la cloche
vous activer toutes les notifications
comme ça vous serez informé dès qu une
prochaine vidéo arrivera et ça c'est une
très bonne chose
oui en 2021 l'ipad promet plus une
tablette c'est clair alors on peut
l'utiliser comme une tablette on peut se
dire en quête d'une tablette mais si on
veut une tablette je vous conseille plus
un ipad r de 2020 qui est super bien
avec son maître jacques bourdin qui est
une petite bombe atomique que j'utilise
aussi quasiment tous les jours j'adore
cette cette tablette ou alors sur un
ipad 2 8 ème génération bien c'est plus
du tout la même chose là ce dont on
parle c'est d'une autre typologie de
machines on parle d'un impact qui se
révolutionne complètement on parle ici
d'une puce m1 la puce heymans et la puce
qu'on retrouve dans les nouveaux macbook
macbook pro 13 pouces macbook air qui
ont été présentées fin 2020 c'est la
puce qu'on va retrouver dans tous les
macbook
donc ce que vous avez ici eh bien c'est
la puissance d'un macbook en termes de
performance vous avez huit heures au
niveau du gpu 8h au niveau du cpc score
au niveau du north island jeunes c'est
une machine qui est une vraie bombe
atomique et qui tartinent un axe déjà
pour le déverrouiller ces vitesse grand
v ça hyper vite et surtout l'ouverture
d'applications et c'est un truc qui me
plaît beaucoup et que je trouve super
intéressant c'est à dire la réactivité
que vous allez avoir à peine vous
appuyez apple ça s'ouvre mais une
vitesse mais tellement plus rapidement
que ce qu'on avait avancé une machine
qui va très vite c'est une bête de
compet c'est de la vitesse pure
et c'est pour ça que cet ipad propre et
bien c'est pour lui un ipad trop c'est
un vrai petit ordinateur alors ici en
plus avec le magic qui bordent on le
voit très clairement on a affaire un
ordinateur vous venez scrollé à deux
doigts vous pouvez faire la navigation à
trois doigts en plus de ça avec l'apple
pencil et bien c'est pareil il faut
utiliser pour venir dessiner pour venir
naviguer pour faire plein de choses
c'est un super outil si vous voulez une
bête de compet compact vous pouvez
utiliser
aussi bien en format tablette que vous
emmenez avec vous et pouvoir transformer
en ordinateur grâce au magic qui bandent
alors le magic qui borde le coûte un peu
plus cher on sent guère les prix dans
quelques instants saint aignan en tout
cas augmente et l'addition le fait de
points à venir griffonné et naviguer
comme ça directement avec votre apple
paintsil et bien vous avez une machine
qui est absolument incroyable donc ça
c'est le premier point c'est la première
révolution la deuxième révolution
elle s'opère ici au niveau de l'écran
parce qu'ici vous avez plus un écran et
bien comme on pourrait s'attendre en
tout cas les autres zones on avait déjà
un très très bel écran au niveau des
ipad là vous allez beaucoup plus loin
chez apple on se retrouve avec la
technologie mini l'aide alors la
technologie miled ça vous dit quoi en
fait les midinettes sont des led c'est
du lcd sont des lettres qui sont 40 fois
plus petites que des leds standard ce
qui fait que vous allez gagner en
précision au niveau de la couleur il
faut imaginer que vous avez beaucoup
plus de toutes petites led ces fameuses
mini raid vous allez avoir plus de
détails au niveau de vos couleurs des
contrastes qui seront beaucoup plus
prononcée en écran de bien meilleure
qualité que ce qu'on avait avant donc ça
c'est premier point c'est la mini l'aide
et ça c'est vraiment génial j'ai voulu
illustrer que les usages dans quelques
jours donc laissez moi encore un petit
peu le temps je vraiment pas tant de
faire une vidéo très complète au niveau
des usages de ce que j'en fais moi pour
la productivité je me remets à la
musique on va parler de musique
également on va parler de dessin je
dessine très mal donc pouvoir parler
simplement pour parler notamment de
lightroom photoshop que j'utilise tous
les jours sur mon macbook pro mais comme
ici on est sur un ordinateur plus qu'une
tablette qui valoir plus de performance
aujourd'hui j'utilise un macbook pro 16
pouces qui utilise un processeur intel
donc là avec le m1 j'ai plus de
performance dans mon ipad pro que dans
mon macbook pro donc ça va être super
intéressant à pouvoir regarder ça donc
laissez moi quelques jours le temps
vraiment d'avancer là dessus vous faire
la vidéo la plus complète possible
en plus de ça vous avez dû promotion'
c'est à dire un taux de rafraîchissement
de 120 hertz et là vous allez de 24 à
120 hertz manque en termes de fluidité
c'est super bien et notamment pour des
expériences de gaming parce que oui
cette tablette vous pouvez utiliser
comme une console peut même d'apprendre
une manette de console pour venir jouer
ici très facilement donc ça c'est aussi
un point qui est extrêmement fort et
super intéressant alors on a un écran
trou tonnes qui va venir s'adapter pour
venir protéger vos yeux on a une gamme
de couleurs p3 enfin une vraie petite
bête
il existe deux tailles d'écran moi j'ai
la 12
8 9 pouces car des scans très grand
existe également une taille d'écran 11
pouces donc ça dépend une fois de plus
de vos besoins vous avez deux versions
vista on l'avait déjà avant dans les
anciens ipad donc c'est pas la grande
grande nouveauté mais c'est toujours
intéressant de venir le préciser vous
avez une version wifi est ce qu'ils
appellent la version c'est lui là c'est
la version avec de la kadji ou de la 5g
et oui parce qu'ici on peut avoir de la
salle j ai vraiment ici shiroka jay
parce que la 5g elles passent pas hyper
hyper bien mais vous avez un modem qui
vous permet d'avoir de la 5g on a
également du wifi et du bluetooth 5.0
d'euros termes de connectivité on est
quand même relativement tranquille autre
point qui est intéressant de vivre
charger directement ici en usb sait
alors ce n'est pas tout nouveau tout
nouveau c'était déjà le cas l'année
dernière ce qui est bien c'est le
pouvaient venir brancher un moniteur
externe pour utiliser la puissance de
votre puce m1 pour venir faire tous les
calculs et vous mettez un pro x dr
displayed vous savez les gros éditeurs
professionnels d'apple derrière eh bien
vous avez une bête de compet
alors il ya une autre fonctionnalité qui
est toute nouvelle est que j'adore je
vais vous montrer c'est une
fonctionnalité de suivi lorsque vous
venez passer un coup de fil or les coups
de fil aujourd'hui en pages de plus en
plus au niveau des différentes
applications de visioconférence a va
être notamment du zoom ça va être du web
ex avec ce que vous voulez et vous avez
un truc absolument incroyable et j'adore
qui était développé ici donc là regardez
par exemple sur facetime je passe un
petit coup de fil c'est très simple ce
qui va se passer c'est cuba moi je bouge
je vis donc ce qui fait que si je me
décale sur le côté comme ça
eh bien voyez ça se décale directement
temps réel c'est pareil de la même
manière si je me lève et bien ça vient
se lever pour me suivre
donc j'ai un vrai tracking j'ai ensuite
l'eau dépassé sur le côté eh bien ça
monsieur dans la limite bien évidemment
de ce qu'est capable de faire votre
caméra ici je me rapproche
eh bien ça va se rapprocher de la même
manière ici je prends ma chaise et que
je me rassois parce que moi j'ai envie
de m'asseoir et bien ça me suis
exactement de la même manière et ce truc
là c'est super intéressant pour ça parce
que ils ont compris un truc chez à peu
et c'est extrêmement malsain c'est
qu'aujourd'hui avec cette crise du
coville il fait passer toutes nos
journées à faire de la vision tout cas
beaucoup à faire de la visio et bien on
n'est pas toujours statique par contre
on voit pas toujours déplacer notre
caméra du conte bouche un petit peu donc
à vous pouvez venir bouger un petit peu
vient vous levez finir vous déplacer
aller sur le côté vous mettre de l'autre
côté
votre caméra vous suit pour venir faire
vos visions et ça c'est vraiment génial
regarde et me mettre en bas ça me suis
en main et c'est ouf c'est absolument
ruf donc à un vrai tracking havre est
suivi au niveau de mon fils
donc en termes d'expérience en termes d'
usage ça c'est vraiment génial
autre point quel super intéressant vous
pouvez monter jusqu'à deux terrains de
stockage louis deux terrains de stockage
c'est tout simplement énorme avec vous
réellement besoin de terra pas
nécessairement vous partez de 128 go de
stockage jusqu'à deux terrains moi aussi
j'ai une version avec intérêt et c'est
déjà énorme autant dire qu'on peut
revenir stocker vraiment des masala
dépendre une fois de plus de vos besoins
et de vos usages mais si vous avez
besoin de faire de la vidéo et que vous
avez besoin de stocker des fichiers
volumineux et bien les deux terrains il
pourra vous voulez falloir moi dans mon
macbook ou j'ai pas du terrain j'ai un
terrain ce qui est déjà très bien
les deux terrains choix c'est vraiment
génial donc ça c'est super intéressant
puisqu'on est sur les caméras reste on
dit à l'arrière vous le voyez vous avez
pas moins de deux caméras alors vous
allez avoir un grand-angle de 12
mégapixels en ultra grand-angle de 10
mégapixels alors ça on en reparlera plus
tard lors des usages conviendra ça que
vous et votre caméra leader à votre
caméra leader qui va être là pour la
réalité augmentée et qui sera là
également pour faire des photos lorsque
vous avez moins de lumière ce que va
venir faire la caméra lidar sait mesurer
les distances tout simplement elle va
dire ben tiens la personne en face elle
est à un mètre
eh bien je vais faire le point la
netteté un mètre donc ça s'est vraiment
bien aussi en terme en terme d' usage
pour la réalité augmentée quelque chose
auquel croit énormément tim cook eh bien
il ya un vrai intérêt derrière en plus
hot spot est super intéressant c'est que
vous avez cinq micros qualité studio
pour revenir et bien faire des
enregistrements pour venir converser de
la même manière avec facetime et toutes
vos applications pour venir discuter
travail et collaborer bien c'est
vachement bien parce que vous allez
avoir une superbe expérience audio pas
moins de quatre haut parleurs ça c'est
pas nouveau nouveau un certain qu'on
avait déjà dans les ipad pro monde a
toujours ici quatre haut parleurs avec
une vraie bonne qualité une vraie bonne
spatialisation et si vous avez des
accessoires signés apple à savoir dr
paul ce projet repose ou pourquoi pas un
erp aux max et bien vous allez augmenter
significativement l'expérience lors de
vos vidéos de vos appels de vos
divertissements regarder un film sur des
deux flics ce mic canal ce que vous
voulez autres et qu'on sent donc ça
s'est vraiment bien
apple nous allons surtout nous middaugh
peu près 10 heures alors ça dépend des
usages ça dépend de ce que vous allez en
faire si vous avez des applications qui
viennent être un peu gourmande elle est
dix heures vous ne les aurais pas a
contrario si ce n'est que du vide
deux films et de séries avec une
luminosité à 50% diary dira ça dépendra
vraiment pas plus de ce que vous allez
venir en faire mais ça ça on en parle
dans quelques jours le temps vraiment
vous faire cette vidéo complète sur les
usages on va regarder tout ce qu'on peut
faire avec cette machine là et c'est
pour ça que c'est super intéressant
parce qu ici et je vous dis une fois de
plus on n'est pas sur un ipad telle
qu'on avait l'habitude de les connaître
on avait déjà des ipads seront
extrêmement performant les années
précédentes mais là c'est plus la même
chose c'est une toute nouvelle histoire
qui s'écrit et c'est pour ça que si vous
voulez acheter vous un ipad pro en 2021
gars c'est maintenant qu'il faut changer
c'est maintenant qu'il faut aller là
dessus parce que cette machine elle est
absolument incroyable et absolument
performante et elle vous permet de faire
tellement de choses mais tellement de
choses à leur pousse tellement les
horizons vous l'utilisez mais je vous le
dis une fois de plus comme un ordinateur
central c'est vraiment un mi chemin
entre la tablette et l'ordinateur vous
avez la pluie sens à l'état pur vous
avez de la puissance brute bien plus
puissant que la plupart des ordinateurs
intel absolument il faut vraiment le
voir comme ça et c'est ça qui est
vraiment g l alors le tarif est un peu
élevé
l'ipad pro on se pousse on commence à
899 euros qui vous partez sur les 12
pouces 9 comme j'ai ici vous commencez à
128 giga 1219 euros moi j'ai la version
avec 1 tera et intérêts on est à 1089
euros mais comme en plus je suis en wifi
+ cellular c'est à dire que c'est la
version wifi classique et la petite est
d'avoir une carte sim 5 g ce qui est le
cas ici
eh bien je monte à 2159 euros et encore
je ne suis pas sans la version en de
terrain vous là vous monte quand même
beaucoup plus haut pour moi l'accessoire
indispensable
c'est plus un accessoire c'est vrai
parce que vendu en kit c'est
complètement normal c'est le magic qui
vendent alors magic band je vous l'avais
déjà présenté l'année dernière c'est
pour moi
l'indispensable plus plus plus plus plus
ici sans votre ipad a pas de pros et
ipad r également parce que vous le
transformer en petit ordinateur n'a pas
besoin de le recharger
ça c'est vraiment génial parce qu'il a
bien utilisé et bien la ligne que vous
avez directement dans votre ipad grâce
aux petits connecteurs que vous avez ici
au dos donc ça c'est génial
en plus de ça ça vous permet de venir le
recharger directement la lah sur la
gauche parce que l'ipad wi il se
recharge lui mais sur la droite pour
vous l'avez face à vous enfin faut les
mettre dans l'autre sens qui vous voulez
mais en gros ce que vous le posez dessus
eh bien il vient se recharge est là donc
ça c'est pareil ça vous permet d'avoir
un point de charge de l'autre
côté donc que vous soyez d'un côté ou
l'autre vous avez de l'achat mais par
contre voir les votre ipad
il se transforme complètement il devient
un petit ordinateur vous avez votre
petit trackpad c'est pour moi une
combinaison gagnante alors après et pour
tout les infographistes et pour plein de
personnes vous avez l'apple pencil c'est
je dirais l'objet le plus facultatif là
dessus moi j'utilise pas beaucoup mais
je vais aller l'utiliser davantage pour
vraiment vous montrer les différentes
applications lors pour venir décider
pour venir illustrer pour venir faire
différents types de créatures vous
l'avez et en plus ce qui est génial avec
son ipad pro et ça repart à une fois de
plus dans les usages c'est vous pouvez
utiliser comme moniteur externe avec un
macbook pro bon alors ce qui est dingue
c'est que mon macbook pro aujourd'hui à
moi avec moins performant que cet ipad
pro là mais par contre je peux toujours
utilisé comme un petit moniteur externe
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit vraiment
l' usage aujourd'hui qu'il faille faire
là dessus en tout cas ça permet
d'augmenter ma zone de travail ça c'est
intéressant et vous avez un autre
accessoire alors si vous voulez pas le
le magic qui bordent ce serait quand
même dommage si vous ne voulez pas eh
bien vous avez le smart folio d'apple
qui viendra le protéger parce qu'il faut
quand même vraiment tenir le protéger
plus plus plus plus vous le prenez vous
le mettez dedans de la même manière
et là on suivra les trouver la position
vous voulez hop là comme ça ça me fait
un petit cheval et ça vous fait un
support vous le refermer vous le posez
comme ça vous venez positionner votre
appleton si hop là directement dessus
alors attention que le côté mante et à
ne pas le faire tomber dans un sac une
sacoche ou à ce qu'il tombe pas comme ça
parce que c'est complètement possible
pour vraiment faire faire gaffe à ça
c'est le petit pois un peu de détails
ici le magic qui bordent coûte 399 euros
sur la version 12,9 pouces et le smart
folio coûte 109 euros sur la version
également 12,9 me savard vous l'aurez
compris moi cet ipad pro 12,9 pouce de
je vous le recommande plus plus plus
plus plus alors pour l'acheter il faut
venir péter la tirelire et casser le pel
c'est une certitude mais lorsque vous
venez d'acheter faut pas raisonner en
disant je m'achète une tablette parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est plus le cas lorsque
vous venez choisir cette machine là vous
venez pas acheter une tablette vous
achetez un ordinateur vous venez acheter
la puce et main vous venez acheter un
écran miled vous venez acheter pourquoi
pas de la 5g mais c'est pas obligatoire
vous venez acheter de la performance à
l'état brut une machine qui marche
merveilleusement bien et que vous
emmènera vraiment loin au niveau des
différents usages
donc voilà ce que j'avais à vous dire
aujourd'hui j'ai préféré prendre le
temps pour vous la présenter comme ça et
tout
et parce que c'est plus une tablette
l'ipad pro n'est plus une tablette
l'ipad pour se situe entre un mac avec
une puce henin est une tablette ipad r
wan ipad pro générations antérieures
c'est vraiment une bête de compet moi
j'adore très clairement donc laissez moi
quelques bonne bonne bonne bonne bonne
journée le temps de vous préparer cette
vidéo complète pour regarder les
différents usages répondre à la question
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire de cet ipad
ok un ipad pro c'est génial ok il ya
beaucoup de performances mais pour quoi
faire
quel besoin j'en ai ça on en reparle
d'ici quelques jours d'ici là je vous
invite à me dire vous ce que vous en
pensez bien évidemment en bas en
commentaire comment vous trouvez vous
avez déjà un ipad pro qu'est ce que vous
pensez de celui 1 qu'est ce que vous
pensez de la puce aimant et de l'écran
mini l'aide dans cette machine à danser
monstres là clairement dites moi ce que
vous en pensez en bas n'oubliez pas de
vous abonner et laisser toutes vos
questions en bas en commentaire et dites
moi aussi en termes d'usagé qu'est ce
que vous voudriez qu'on regarde si vous
avez des usages un peu particulier vous
voulez qu'on regarde pour cette
prochaine vidéo sur les usages sur
l'ipad pro d'ici là des bisous de la
bourre pour les soins de vous il ya très
vite ciao